one of the things i've been talking
about for quite some time is that the
only place that there's real racism left
in america
is on the left right like of course
there are individual racist people there
there are bad people it's just how it is
there are mean people there are people
who do not like black people there are
people who don't like jews there are
people who don't like white people there
are people who don't like gays there are
people who don't like straights but the
only place in america that any of this
is okay and not only okay but actually
manufactured and then pushed out via
giant corporations
is on the left so msnbc peddles in this
social justice nonsense all the time
they constantly attack white people
constantly attack christians constantly
attack straight people it's what the the
network is doing now you may wonder why
would nbc a giant corporation be just
pushing racism all day long but that is
the the path that i suppose msnbc has
decided is right in terms of making
money because at the end of the day
these guys just want to make money so
michael eric dyson who is a professor
who has been on uh bill maher's show
probably two dozen times um
he
was on joy reads show
now you know joy reid this woman is not
well um if you pretend you're watching
her show from a mental institution it
makes a hell of a lot more sense uh he
was on joy reid's show and he was
attacking winsome sears now who is
winsome sears well of course as you guys
know last week
glenn younkin won the virginia
governor's race over terry mcauliffe
terry mcauliffe was the democrat who
said that parents shouldn't have
anything to do with their kids education
critical race theory isn't in schools
you're all a bunch of racist blah blah
blah just a bad dude so finally we got
that hope right i'm always talking about
the hope in the distance and we got some
hope by yanking winning absolutely well
winsome sears is the lieutenant
governor-elect now she happens to be a
black woman now you would think that
michael eric dyson and joy reid and the
people over at msnbc who are always
talking about systemic racism might be
happy when a black woman becomes so
successful but they're not into it
here's michael eric dyson problem is
here they want they want white supremacy
by ventriloquist effect there is a black
mouth moving but a white idea through
the running on the runway of the tongue
of a figure who justifies and
legitimates of the white supremacist
practices we know that we can
internalize in our own minds in our own
subconscious and our own bodies the very
principles that are undoing us so to
have a black face
speaking in behalf of a white
supremacist legacy is nothing new and it
is to the chagrin of those of us who
study race that the white folk on the
other side and the right wingers on the
other side don't understand this is
politics 101 and this is race not even
one-on-one what's beneath one-on-one
it's the it's the pre-k of race you
should understand the fact that if you
tell black people look i support a negro
look there is a person of color that i
am in favor of and that person of color
happens to undermine and undercut and
subvert the very principles about which
we are concerned you do yourself no
service by pointing to them as an
example of your racial progressivism
god there's an awful lot there first off
i just want to reiterate you will not
find anything nearly that racist on fox
news today
or on newsmax tomorrow or any of those
right-wing media outlets that these
people are always freaking out about
that was abject pure racism not reverse
racism not special racism it was just
old-fashioned racism
he thinks that this black woman wins
some series who has a pretty pretty
fantastic resume and and if you watch
some of her talk on the on election
night like this woman's pretty
spectacular okay and i don't care about
the color of her skin these people
racialize everything and then we have to
unfortunately respond to it his line
there a black mouth moving but white
idea running on the runway
like how disgusting is that
ideas don't have color you're allowed to
be whatever color you are and have
different ideas but he thinks that the
color of his skin is the totality of his
ideas and that is so dangerous it is
actually racism it is the very
definition of prejudice which is to
prejudge so if you just saw a black
person walking down the street and you
judge them as if i must know all of the
things you think because you're black
that would be prejudice right so the
more that black people succeed the more
that these race hucksters and that's
what they are the more they will get
angry but this guy michael eric dyson
has been doing this for years and years
and years and as i said he's on bill
maher's show all the time he was
actually on this friday and i'll get to
that in just a second but michael
reminded me that he actually did a
debate with jordan peterson this is
about two and a half years ago a little
bit before covet i think maybe i was on
tour with jordan at the time if i'm not
mistaken about two and a half years ago
and they were debating uh race and a
whole bunch of other stuff you know all
the all the stuff that we always talk
about on this show these are the monk
debates and here's michael eric dyson
and then listen to jordan peterson's
response but that is to be complicit in
the very problem itself terminologically
you're beginning at a point this that's
already uh productive and controversial
you're saying how can he get his
equality back who are you talking about
jordan peterson trending number one on
twitter
jordan peterson with an international in
an international bestseller i want him
to tweet something out about me and my
book
jordan peterson right
this is what i'm saying to you why the
rage bro
you you're doing well but you're a mean
mad white man
and you're gonna get us right
and
well
what i derived from that
series of rebuttals let's say is twofold
the first is that
saying that the radical left goes too
far when they engage in violence is not
a sufficient response by any stretch of
the imagination because there are sets
of ideas in radical leftist thinking
that led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea not at the level of violent action
it's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence it's like being
against poverty it's like you know
generically speaking decent people are
against
poverty and violence doesn't address the
issue in the least
and with regards to
my privilege or lack thereof i mean i'm
not making the case that i haven't had
advantages in my life and disadvantages
in my life like most people you don't
know anything about my background or
where i came from but it doesn't matter
to you because fundamentally i'm a mean
white man that's a hell of a thing to
say in a debate
[Music]
god i love that ending there by jordan
right like you don't know anything about
my life but fundamentally i'm a mean
white man like that's what you've
distilled my existence down to i just
want to say one other thing just on the
on the jordan front and by the way i'm
interviewing jordan tomorrow i talked to
him this morning and we're going to do a
little different type of interview than
we normally would it's going to be a
little more push and pull and open a
conversation
but when i was on tour with jordan for a
year and a half
i never saw him angry
there were times that he was sort of
upset about something or he would get a
hit piece written whatever but he would
always try to to give the benefit of the
doubt to the writer he would always try
to
de-escalate tensions all of those things
but all
dyson
has left is you're a mean white man i
mean really i know you guys know jordan
well enough is he a mean white man and
if he is mean does it have anything to
do with his skin color and has he ever
said he's better than anyone because of
his skin color so i love the way jordan
just calmly and rationally did that